yes in Paris the Eiffel Tower was one of  the structures that went dark but only  for five minutes security concerns meant  that was the longest the lights could be  turned off in Rome st. Peter's  disappeared into the darkness for the  full 60 minutes the project is called  Earth Hour and it's the brainchild of  the environmental group WWF each hour a  new time zone joined in at eight-thirty  p.m. local time it wasn't just major  landmarks office blocks and hotels  joined in to like here in Jakarta the  events been held every year since 2007  this year organizers were expecting more  than 7,000 cities to be involved  worldwide botanical new Athens joined  the global effort by turning off the  illumination of its most famous landmark